invité de ce 12 13 la fille de robert
boulin fabienne boulin-burgeat bonjour
vous étiez déjà demandé en vain la
réouverture de l'anc est
vous pensez que ces nouveaux témoignages
vont faire la différence cette fois bien
écoutez c'est un combat difficile depuis
30 ans la thèse officielle reste
inchangée depuis 79 alors que des faits
nouveaux s'accumulent qui montre et
démontre qu'il s'agit bien d'un
assassinat
j'aimerais que la justice de mon pays il
courage de lever le voile de la vérité
sur cette affaire et cette fois ça vous
semble encore plus solide que la
dernière fois bien côté c'est très
solide parce qu'en plus il y à des
témoins de grande qualité que l'on ne
peut pas remettre en cause comme
monsieur me charbonnel et justement le
jean charbonnel site deux personnalités
politiques qui pourraient être impliqués
vous savez qui ça peut être mais non
parce que je n'ai pas vu monsieur
charbonnel mois donc on n'a pas discuté
mais de toute façon moi je demande à la
justice de faire la vérité c'est mais il
faut bien sûr entendre ce témoin là qui
est capital quand même et dans votre for
intérieur vous vous avez une idée de qui
aurait pu commandité cet assassinat six
assassinats y est vous écoutez je me
doute en tout cas d'effectivement de en
tout cas de l'entourage et 2
je sais bien que ces politiques oui vous
avez toujours dénoncé un complot
aujourd'hui et des langues qui se
délient à votre avis qui a intérêt
trente ans après à couvrir encore secret
mais un côté monsieur charbonnel dit que
ces personnalités qui seraient impliqués
dans l'assassinât sont toujours vivants
donc vous voyez les assassins courent
toujours
et en plus quand on fera la vérité sur
cette affaire
on montrera les vols laisse que les
enquêtes escamoter les vols de sceller
les choses considérable qui montre que
notre de notre société est malade et
qu'il les temps peut-être que que on
nettoie les écuries d'augias
et qu'en face la vérité sur cet
assassinat et si la justice française
reste sourde à ce nouvel appel
jusqu'où êtes vous prêtez à l'écumé
voilà donc s'il nous allons faire une
demande de réouverture et si celle ci
n'est pas acceptée on ira jusqu'à la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
bien entendu merci beaucoup
fabienne boulin burgeat d'avoir répondu
à notre invitation